Today we're going to learn about the concept of consideration by exploring the
classic Cesnet of a case Hamer versus Sidway,
which was decided by the New York Court of Appeals in 1891.
The facts of this family dispute are memorable.
William III story senior promised to pay his nephew William he story the second
$5,000.
If the ladder would refrain from drinking,
using tobacco,
swearing and playing cards or billiards for money until he became 21 years of
age,
the nephew agreed and performed his promise.
Uh,
on his 21st birthday,
the nephew requested the $5,000 and the uncle told him that he had had the money
certain but that it would be held from him until the uncle thought the nephew
was capable of taking care of it after the uncle's death.
This suit was brought by the plaintiff and the present appellant,
Louisa Haimer.
She was the assignee of the nephew.
After several mean assignments,
that's it looks like it's spelled Mez,
but it means it's pronounced mean and it means intermediate assignments.
So it's where the nephew,
we design his interest in bringing this case to somebody else who ultimately
assigned it a to Louisa Haimer,
the other party,
Franklin Sidway was the executor of the uncle's estate and who was claiming that
the estate didn't have to pay the $5,000.
The central issue in the case is this is forbearance from arguably harmful
activity like drinking sufficient consideration to support a contract.
Um,
Sidway representing the uncle's estate argued that the uncles promise to pay
wasn't enforceable because the agreement lacked the necessary consideration.
We need to understand the concept of consideration because consideration is a
traditional prerequisite to enforcing a contractual promise.
Section 17 of the second restatement of contracts provides the formation of a
contract requires a bargain in which there is a manifestation of mutual assent
to the exchange and a consideration.
By the way,
was there a manifestation of mutual assent and in hammer you bet the uncle made
an offer and the case says the nephew assented from that moment on both parties
were bound to a contract.
That is if there is sufficient consideration once the contractual bell rings,
the nephew would have breached a contract created by the exchange of promises if
he drank at any point after,
uh,
promising.
So in Hamer versus Sidway,
uh,
it's included in most contract case book because it helps teach us what counts
as consideration.
So to begin,
it's helpful to think of consideration as what's given in return for somebody,
someone else's promise.
It is the quid given for the quo and the phrase quid pro quo.
Sidway argued that in return for the uncles promise,
the nephew hadn't given up enough because the nephew had only promised to
forbear from doing things that would have harmed him.
The court rejected Sidway his argument and found there was a sufficient
consideration quote.
A valuable consideration in the sense of the law may consist either in some
right interest,
profit or benefit accruing to the one party or some forbearance loss or
responsibility given suffered or undertaken by the other under Hamer versus
Sidway.
A return promise to be a sufficient consideration doesn't have to be an actual
detriment.
It is enough for it to be a legal detriment to the promise.
See,
illegal detriment means promising to do anything that you didn't have to do or
promising to forbear from doing anything that you might have legally done.
The case is interesting because the uncle didn't receive any obvious benefit and
one might plausibly argue the nephew did not suffer an actual detriment from the
performance of his promise.
Thus,
the court's conclusion that illegal detriment for purposes of consideration can
be very different from the common sense meaning of what an actual detriment is.
The Hammer decision is a classic statement of the benefit detriment conception
of consideration.
Under this definition,
either an actual benefit to the promise or or a legal detriment to the promise
see is a sufficient consideration because it's hard to factually established
whether the promise sore here,
the uncle actually benefited from his nephew's abstinence.
The benefit detriment conception of consideration almost always looks to whether
there was illegal detriment.
One way of establishing a promise or his benefit would be to rely on the
economic concept of revealed preference.
The uncle must have benefited from the nephews,
abstinence or the uncle wouldn't have been willing to pay for it,
but the revealed preference argument proves too much.
The consideration requirement is meant to preclude legal enforcement of
gratuity.
Gratuitous promises,
promises for which there is no return promise,
but anyone who promises to give $1,000 a gratuitously to another reveals a
preference for that state of the world.
That gratuitous promise doesn't reveal that the promise or gained anything from
the promises,
a return promise when there isn't one.
The problem with the legal detriment,
conception of consideration is that savvy contractors could manipulate the
return promise to qualify as a legal detriment.
For example,
Jane offers to pay Joe $10,000 if Joe promises to inhale sometimes in the next
60 seconds,
Joe readily agrees and then loudly and hails Jane then refuses to pay.
And when Joe Sues for breach of contract,
Jane has the audacity to argue that there was no consideration for her promise
to pay $10,000 the question here is under the benefit detriment conception of
consideration should Jane when,
and the answer to this quiz is no.
Joe had a legal right to hold his breath for a minute.
His promise to forbear from holding his breath is the legal detriment,
creating consideration for Jane's promise to pay $10,000.
Even though courts wanted to avoid having to assess the messy factual,
a question of whether the promise or actually benefits from the promises.
Return promise,
the Joe and Jane Hypothetical show why the promise or benefit question is hard
to avoid.
If we want to stop,
uh,
hold your breath.
Types of shapes.
Shenanigans,
the common law of responded to this problem in cases decided after Hamer versus
Sidway,
um,
by replacing the early conception of consideration as either a benefit to the
promise or or a detriment to the primacy with what is known as the bargain for
conception of consideration.
This bargain for or inducement conception of consideration can be seen in
section 71 of the restatement second of contracts to constitute consideration,
a performance or return prominence must be bargained for.
And then section two tells us that a performance or return promise is bargain
for if it is sought by the promise or in exchange for his promise.
And is given by the promise see and exchange for that promise.
In contrast to the benefit detriment of consideration which focuses on the
welfare of the parties.
The bargain for conception focuses on the parties reasons for entering into the
transaction.
Although the benefit detriment framework still exerts considerable influence in
England and Commonwealth countries.
The bargain for theory has largely won the day in the United States.
That said,
because contract law is a product of judicial decisions,
it has many authors and old rules die hard.
Although the bargain for theory is the dominant approach to consideration the
benefit and detriment test still figure into many courts holdings.
Section 79 of the second restatement states that if the requirement of
consideration is met,
there's no additional requirement of a gain advantage or benefit to the promise
or or have a loss disadvantage or detriment to the primacy common be to the same
section observes that some courts say illegal detriment is sufficient even
though there is no economic detriment or at or other actual loss,
but suggest that it's more realistic to say simply that there is no requirement
of detriment anymore.
Another way of looking at the haimer versus Sidway case is that the court isn't
really looking for a benefit or a legal detriment,
but simply for a bargain for exchange,
the uncle has offered to pay $5,000 in exchange for the nephews clean living.
Isn't it fairly clear that the return promise was sought by the promise or in
exchange for this return promise?
After all,
we don't think the uncle would have been willing to make his promise to pay
unless the nephew had made his promise in return.
Thus,
the facts of the case,
if not the court's actual language,
provide support for the second restatements bargained for rule that neither our
benefit nor,
uh,
an actual detriment is essential.
Finally,
a close reading of the case reveals that the uncle in Hamer versus Sidway made
two separate promises,
one on March 20th at a wedding anniversary,
and the second one in a letter of February six 1875.
The court's analysis of the case focuses entirely on whether the first promise
was supported by consideration,
but the suit is more,
I think,
accurately premised on the second progress.
The nephews consideration for,
uh,
the uncle second promise was different.
The nephews promise not to drink or smoke was the consideration for the first
promise.
And even if there was no consideration for that first promise,
the second promise might well be supported consideration for the second promise.
This nephew gave up a plausible s a lawsuit for breach of the first promise in
exchange for the uncles promise to pay $5,000 plus interest giving up the right
to sue was arguably a settlement of a claim and separately enforceable.
So what have we learned?
Consideration is a requirement for a contractual promise to be enforced under
hammer consideration could be either a promise or benefit,
or more likely a legal detriment to the promise.
See,
and finally,
because of the problems with the legal detriment test being manipulated,
modern courts 10 now to require that the promise or his return promise was
bargained for,
that the return promise actually induce the promise or to make his or her
promise.